When a man and woman love each other very
much (and sometimes not) they end up making
a baby.
And the woman's body goes through a ton of
changes, but then again, so does the man's!
Pregnancy causes a lot of visible (and invisible)
changes to mom bods.
Mental, physical, hormonal, emotional, and
so on… but the moms aren't alone in this
brand new world, science has finally begun
to recognized Dads might be going through
changes right alongside.
In 2007, a study came out describing Couvade
syndrome -- also known as sympathetic pregnancy.
The study followed more than 500 men and found
a majority of the men displayed pregnancy-associated
symptoms of morning sickness, stomach cramps,
mood swings, and a few developed swollen stomachs
(called pseudocyesis).
A ton of studies have documented these sympathetic
effects, which worsen as the pregnancy progresses,
clearing up after the birth.
They're not sure exactly what causes Couvade
Syndrome, but they think it's psychosomatic
-- or caused by the mind; thus, it's not a
medical condition, but a psychological one.
So though sympathetic pregnancy might be caused
by anxiety, attention-seeking behavior, or
as a quote "statement of paternity" as some
hypotheses say… there are actual changes
men go through during pregnancy.
Male marmosets and cotton-top tamarins, primates
with similar child-rearing practices to humans,
gain as much as 20 percent of their body weight
during their mate's pregnancy -- perhaps to
store extra energy in preparation of raising
their offspring.
Studies in humans found cortisol (a stress
hormone) and prolactin (lactation hormones)
spike in men alongside their pregnant ladies.
Recently, a study from the University of Michigan
found surprising hormonal changes in fathers
which started rather quickly.
Within the first 12 weeks of their mate's
pregnancy, testosterone and estradiol levels
dropped in the Dads-to-be, and the drop continued
to throughout the pregnancy.
The researchers admitted they don't know why,
but they expect it has something to do with
the changes the woman's body is going through,
perhaps to prepare the men as they quote "transition
to fatherhood."
Anecdotally, it might be a good thing for
testosterone to drop, as it's associated with
aggression, risk-taking and sexual savoir
faire; but curiously it rose in women over
the same period!
Estradiol is similar to estrogen, and estrogen
in men hasn't been very thoroughly studied;
though scientists think a drop in estrogen
in men show symptoms similar to menopause
in women: i.e. -- decreased bone density,
a decline in libido, and fat around their
midsection.
And finally… we can't talk about fatherhood
without mentioning the infamous Dadbod; well,
sort of.
Men who lived with their child gained 2.6
percent in their BMI or an average of 2 kilograms.
Men who lived apart still gained one-and-a-half
kilos, or a 2 percent BMI increase.
The study, in the American Journal of Men's
Health found lifestyle changes caused weight
gain, but could this be explained by a lowering
of estradiol levels?
Maybe?
Ultimately, most of the studies of pregnancy
are lady-facing, which makes ALL the sense,
but to completely dismiss or ignore men because
they're not actually pregnant seems kinda
stupid; especially in light of the surprising
science we've seen.
Humans evolved two-parent caregiving to give
our offspring the best parental resources
available and that does seem to extend pre-birth.
Say it with me now.
More.
Research.
Is.
OBVIOUSLY.
Needed.
What do you think about sympathetic pregnancy?
Is it real?
Have any of you experienced it?
We KNOW some of you out there are parents.
Hey parents, if you haven't subscribed, go
sign in and subscribe.
Really.
You won't regret it.
And we'd love to know you're out there, so
we can make more videos for you too.
Do y'all know some other things about pregnancy?
Are you sure they're not myths?
Check out this video where I debunked some
tall tales about birthin'